>> Speaker 1: From the Library
of Congress in Washington DC.
>> David L. Paterson:
Good afternoon.
Many of you have read
some of Katherine's work.
Some of you have met her and
some of you know her very well.
I've had the honor of knowing her
for 50 years, 120 days, six hours
and give her to a couple of minutes.
My mom, I'm very proud
to introduce her.
[ Applause and Cheering ]
Many of you know her
works of fiction.
She's an incredible storyteller,
but as her son growing up with her,
there were many stories that we
enjoyed that were from our history
and our lives, which she
would be talking about today.
So I'm not going to
waste any more time
with me bragging about my mother.
I'm going to introduce
her, Katherine Paterson.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> Katherine Paterson: Hi.
Thank you for coming
to this large room.
I walked in a little nervous,
but I see that my friends
and relatives are here,
so that helps.
I'm delighted to be here.
I was listening to David speaking.
I had already told my children
that none of them could speak
in my funeral because all they
do is get up and make fun of me.
And now, maybe I'll have to
reconsider because, you know,
they might say something nice.
It's really, really great.
I always swore that I
would never write a memoir.
One, I don't have a good enough
memory to write a memoir.
And two, I could not believe that
those who are nearest and dearest
to me would want to be minor
characters in the story of my life.
So then, I began to realize
that some of the stories
that I've been told by my
parents were not being told
to my children and my grandchildren.
At that time, my husband is
quite ill and I was not--
anyway, ready to write another
novel, so I thought this is the time
to write down some of those stories.
I gave them to my friend
and it's a graph to read.
And I just said, "Katherine,
if you're thinking
of publishing these,"
which of course,
any writers always
thinking of publishing.
And she said, "You've got to
connect the stories of your life
with the stories you have written.
So I went back and rewrote
and tried to do that.
Now, when people asked
me about my memoir,
I patiently say that
it is a non memoir.
It is not a connected narrative
the way a real memoir should be.
And they said, "Well, what is it?"
"It's just stories in my life."
"And what is the name of it?"
"Stories of My Life."
[ Laughter ]
So here it is.
And I sort of start out
by asking three questions
that we're not talking to children
because my audience
is often of children.
The three questions which
I am most often I ask,
when did you first begin to right?
How did you become a writer?
Two, where do you get your ideas?
And three, how does
it feel to be famous?
Now, you understand
I write for children,
and my fame such as it is
is at a very narrow world.
But, I'm going to read to you
first of all my answer or most
of my answer to the question,
how does it feel to be famous.
The questioner is young and
earnest and has just confided
that although she doesn't
know what she wants to be,
she knows that she
wants to be famous.
I don't really know how
to answer her question.
How does it feel to be famous?
And then I remember things that
happened after Bridge to Terabithia,
the Newbery Medal, I would
be invited somewhere to speak
and there would be a lovely dinner
at which I was the honored guest.
The people on either side of me
at the table would say something
gracious and congratulatory.
And then they would turn to
the person on the other side
and never speak to me
again for the entire meal.
There were a few times when the
person in charge made it clear
that she'd hire me out for
the weekend and she did expect
to get her money's worth.
I'd come home and whine to
my long suffering husband.
"I'm a human being."
I'd say. "Why can't you just
treat me like a human being?"
And then I remembered Anita.
When I was in Chandler Junior
High School in Richmond, Virginia,
all of us new kids were
put in the same homeroom.
It was a wonderful thing because we
could make friends with each other.
We didn't have to try to cope
with the already cemented cliques
that populated the
rest of the school.
I made several friends that
year, but there was one new girl
that we were all shy around.
The reason we were shy around
Anita was because she was famous.
She was the youngest member
of the Carter sisters.
Her mother, Maybelle, had been part
of the legendary country
music group the Carter Family.
Her older sister June went
on to marry Johnny Cash.
At that time, her old sister and
her mother and Anita sang regularly
on the radio and in
concerts all over the South.
We didn't make friends with Anita,
because we didn't know what to say
to someone who was famous.
Because she had moved around the
country a lot, Anita needed catching
up in a couple of subjects.
And for some reason, I
was asked to tutor her.
I'm sure it was not in Math.
To my amazement she was so
shy that even one on one,
she barely spoke above a whisper.
Yet that summer, I went
to a concern in the--
at a stadium, and on stage,
Anita was transformed.
The huge crow loved her and she
obviously loved performing for them.
"If it hard for me at 45 to
deal with the little bit of fame
that I have, how must
it have been for Anita?"
I wondered.
So I wrote Come Sing Jimmy Jo about
James, a shy boy who becomes a star.
If you want to know what
Katherine Paterson is really like,
you should read that book.
Like James and perhaps
Anita, I'm a shy show-off,
a very private person
who loves to perform.
When my friend Nancy Graff read this
section on feeling famous she said,
"Oh come on, Katherine, you know
you get a kick out of being famous."
We both laughed.
I mean, I was thrilled to be
introduced to the empress of Japan
and hear her say, "Katherine
Paterson?
Who wrote Bridge to Terabithia?"
Sometimes I can't believe
my own life.
I find my self standing on a
stage or sitting at a table
with writers I have known
and admired for many years,
really famous people and
think, "This is me here
with these amazing people."
But that doesn't mean I feel famous.
Famous is not an emotion like
love or hate or jealousy or fear,
feelings with which
I am well acquainted.
You can't feel it, but you
can learn over the years
to sit back and enjoy the perks.
My special friend when
I lived in Takoma Park,
Maryland, was Gene Novovitch.
Gene was an established
writer when I first met her.
But not long after we became friends
my second novel was published,
then the next four that
all won national prizes.
Gene stood by me in my
triumphs, just as she would
through my troubles, and always
with a wonderful sense of humor.
Soon after the first Newbery, I
was scheduled to give a speech
that I knew had to be a good
one, since it seemed to me
that almost every important
children's writer and critic
on both sides of the Atlantic
was going to be in the audience.
We were on vacation at Lake
George, so I sent the speech to Gene
for her comments and
revised accordingly.
But I was still anxious.
I called her and told her
she'd just have to pray for me,
as I was afraid I was
going to fall apart.
Gene, a devout Roman
Catholic, promised she'd pray,
but told me to calm down.
It would be all right.
It was all right.
And I called her to tell
her it had gone all right
and thanked her for her prayers.
"If I'd known how efficacious Roman
Catholic prayers were," I said,
"I might have converted long ago."
"Well, I did pray," she said,
"and he said, "Katherine who?"
[ Laughter ]
When I moved to Vermont, Gene
got in touch with Grace Greene,
a friend I had made soon
after moving, and I--
and told her that as long as I was
in Maryland and even in Virginia,
she had been able to keep me humble,
but Vermont was just too far away,
so she was turning
the job over to Grace.
I wondered if Grace had taken
the job a little too seriously
when she told me the
following story.
A small group of us gather
periodically to do pastel painting
and on the night of January
5th, 2010, I was missing.
Grace had gotten an invitation,
so she knew that I was
in Washington being presented
as the new Ambassador
for Young People's Literature, but
when the others asked where I was,
Grace said, "She's in
Washington being made a
national embarrassment."
When she realized what she had
said, she tried to correct herself.
"Oh, no, I mean natural
embarrassment."
Gene would have loved
that very Freudian slip.
So real friends like mine are
more precious than awards.
Since that's true, I know I am truly
blessed and gratitude, unlike fame,
is something you can actually feel.
Now, I don't think it's a secret
with anyone that I was born
in China, if you know
anything about me.
And twice during my childhood, we
had to come to the United States
because of World War-- of the World
War, first war between and Japan.
And then when it was feared
that America would soon be
in the war, a second evacuation.
By the time I was five, I have
been through war and evacuation
but nothing prepared me for the
American public school system.
I only remember one classmate
from the first grade
at Kinder Park School.
Her name was Martha and
she had a beauty mark
on her cheek beside her lip, which
we all thought was very exotic.
She was the queen of the class,
and although I didn't know much
about Valentine's Day, I knew
hat everyone was expected
to give Martha a valentine.
When the valentines were passed out,
the pile on Martha's desk proved
that everyone, including
me, had complied.
I waited a bit anxiously, but
the valentine delivery boy passed
by my desk every time without
putting anything on it.
I don't think I was
particularly surprised.
I understood somehow that I
was invisible in that class.
But on the way home, I
realized that my older brother
and sister were carrying
valentines they had received,
which they happily showed off
to mother as soon as we arrived.
I was embarrassed when
she asked to see mine.
I hated to confess that I
didn't have any to show.
It seemed like a character flaw.
But mother was outraged, "How could
any teacher let a little girl come
home from first without
a single valentine?"
It was a question she
seemed to pondered more
than once over the years.
After I was an established writer,
she asked me why I
didn't write a story
about the day I didn't
get any valentines.
"Why mother," I said.
"All my books are about the day
I didn't get any valentines."
[ Laughter ]
And then second evacuation in the
United States eventually took us
to Winston-Salem North Carolina
where I became a student,
a very unhappy student at the
Calvin H. Wiley Elementary School.
There were terrible things about
the school for me initially.
But the worst of all was Pansy, the
seventh grade bully, who along were
with her two large friends,
terrorized me on the playground.
Since there were no girl friends
to hang out with during recess,
I would stand trembling as close
to the school building as I could,
watching Pansy and her
friends coming toward me
from the bottom of
the huge playground.
"I'm going to report you,"
she said to me one day.
"You're walking on the grass."
I looked down at the hard,
bare ground under my feet.
"There's no grass here,"
I protested.
"Of course not," she said, "because
people like you keep walking on it."
Now being reported was like
being indicted for a felony.
I lived in dread for days.
I couldn't tell my
parents, they had gone
to my aunt Katherine's
funeral in Lexington.
And even after they returned,
I couldn't tell them.
I was sure the disgrace would have
been too much for them to bear.
Every recess Pansy would tell me
that any moment, I would be called
to the principal's office.
One day I was so frightened that
I broke into tears in music class.
Mrs. Obershein, the beautiful
music teacher quietly took me
out into the hall and gently
asked me what was the matter.
I blurted out my crime
and Pansy's threat.
She didn't laugh.
She didn't even smile.
She simply assured me that I
would not be expelled for walking
on the imaginary grass, indeed
she was quite sure I wouldn't even
be reprimanded.
I should just go to the girls' room
and wash my face and come to class
when I was feeling better.
I recognized that some of my
best writing had its seeds
in that awful year, but I
can't remember once saying
to my nine-year-old
self, "Buck up, old girl.
Someday you're going to make a
mint out of all this misery."
There were, however, a
few people that I remember
with great fondness
from that horrible year.
One was, of course, Mrs. Obershein,
who not only taught me how
to do-re-mi, but also showed
me that there were adults
who could deeply empathize with
a child's irrational fears.
Another was the librarian of
the Calvin H. Wiley School,
who made the library a sanctuary and
a source of comfort and delight--
sorry, in an otherwise
frightening place.
And then-- And then
there was Eugene Hammet,
the other weird kid
in the fourth grade.
I have told the story
of Eugene so many times
that I am sure there are people in
the audience that could lip sync it,
but I can't resist
telling it again here.
In fact at this point, I
usually say, "How many people
in this audience have never heard me
tell the story of Eugene Hammett."
Good. Because I have sworn
I will continue to the story
as long there's one hand goes up.
Though Eugene and I became friends
sometime in the course of that year,
there was an important
difference between me and Eugene.
I was weird through
no choice of my own.
I spoke English, as my
friends in Shanghai had,
with something of a British accent.
I could hardly afford lunch, much
less closes, so my classmates would
from time to time recognize
on my back one
of their own donations to charity.
On December 7th, the Japanese
attacked Pearl Harbor,
and because it was known that I had
come from that part of the world,
there were dark hints that
I might be one of them.
Eugene on the other hand, was weird
by choice or mostly by choice.
I guess he didn't choose his looks.
He was a perfectly round
little boy who wore full-moon,
steel-rimmed glasses, long before
John Lennon made them acceptable,
and sported a half-inch
blond brush cut.
My only ambition in the fourth grade
was to become somehow less weird.
Eugene's declared ambition
was to become a ballet dancer.
In North Carolina, in 1941,
little boys, even well-built
or skinny little boys, did not want
to be ballet dancers
when they grew up.
Now, sometimes outcasts despise each
other, but Eugene and I did not.
We were friends for the rest of the
fourth grade and all of the fifth,
sixth and seventh grades.
During my public school career,
Calvin H. Wiley was the only school
I went to for much more than a year.
And by the time Eugene and
I were in the seventh grade.
I had fulfilled my modest ambition.
I was no longer regarded
as particularly weird.
Eugene on the other hand continued
to march r should I say
dance to a different drummer.
We moved the summer
after seventh grade.
I grew up at last and had a full,
rich life in which people loved me
and didn't call me names,
at least not to my face.
But from time to time over
he years I would think
of Eugene and worry about him.
Whatever could have happened
to my chubby little friend
whose consuming passion was
to become a ballet dancer?
After many decades
and scene changes,
the Paterson family was
living in Norfolk, Virginia,
and our son David had become,
at 17, a serious actor.
But in order to get
the parts he wanted,
he realized that he needed
to take dancing lessons.
There was, however, a problem.
Even in 1983, boys in Norfolk,
Virginia, did not generally aspire
to become ballet dancers.
He asked me to find out
about lessons he could take
without the rest of the
soccer team knowing about it.
My friend Kathryn Morton's daughter
took ballet, so I said to Kathryn,
"David needs to take ballet
lessons, but he's not eager
for all his buddies
to know about it.
Do you have any recommendations?"
"Well," she said.
"If he's really serious,
Gene Hammett at Tidewater Ballet is
the best teacher anywhere around.
Of course, you might find
him a bit strange, but--
" "W-w-w-wait a minute," I said.
"Gene who?"
"Hammett," she said.
"He sends dancers to the
Joffrey and New York City Ballet
and Alvin Ailey every year.
He's especially good
with young black dancers.
Terribly hard on any kid
he thinks has talent,
but he'd give his life for them."
"Gene who?"
I asked again.
"Hammett," she said.
"You may have seen him around town.
He's enormous and wears
his great flowing caftans.
He does look a bit strange,
but he's a wonderful teacher."
"You don't happen to
know where he came from?"
"Well, he came here from New York."
"New York?
He wasn't a dancer?"
"Oh, yes. He was quite
good in his time.
You wouldn't it by
looking at him now,
but he was a fine dancer
20, 30 years ago."
"You wouldn't happen to
know where he grew up?"
"Oh, I don't know," she said.
"North Carolina somewhere I think."
"Next time you see
him, would you ask him
if he remembers anyone
named Katherine Womeldorf
from Calvin H. Wiley School?"
Some days later the phone rings.
"Katherine?"
Said an unknown male voice.
"This is Gene Hammett."
"Eugene! Do you remember me?"
"I even remember a joke you
told me in the fourth grade.
I asked you why if you were born
in China you weren't Chinese.
And you said, 'If a
cat's born in a garage,
does it make it an automobile?'"
[ Laughter ]
See if I started writing then,
I could write funny books.
[ Laughter ]
"And what about you?
You danced in New York, and now
you're famous teacher of ballet.
It's hard to imagine.
You were a little round boy
the last time I saw you."
He laughed.
"Well," he said, "now,
I'm a big round man."
I saw Eugene a number
of times after that,
and he was indeed a big round man.
But I also saw pictures of
him leaping like a Baryshnikov
from the boards of a New York stage.
And even I missed knowing him
when he was slim and gorgeous
and at the height of his career,
I wouldn't give anything for known
that he-- it had happened as
he had determined it would,
back then when we were both
weird little nine-year-old
at Calvin H. Wiley School.
I tried a couple of times
to put Eugene into a novel,
but I found that you can't
put real people into books.
Characters in books
have to be believable.
And real people especially people
like Eugene are simply
not believable.
I did try to put Pansy,
the seventh grade bully
into Bridge to Terabithia.
It was going to be
the perfect revenge
for all those terrifying recess
hours she caused me, but here again,
I don't know why Pansy was a bully.
I know that people aren't born
bullies and that no one is a bully
or a snob, who is comfortable
with himself or herself.
But I had to know why
Janice Avery was a bully.
And when I knew, I
feel sorry for her.
Before I finished the
book, I rather liked her.
It ruined my plan for revenge.
I heard somewhere that unless you
can find yourself in your villain,
he or she will remain in
a cardboard character.
Good advice for fledging
writers, I believe.
I asked David's permission
because the book that--
if you know anything about me,
the book that you know is Bridge
to Terabithia and I asked David's
permission to read the story.
And he gave me that permission.
And this is a story you
may already know again.
But, I'm going to read it and then
we'll take some time for questions.
If the fourth grade at Wiley
School was the most miserable year
of my childhood, I think I would
have to choose the year 1974
as the most painful
year of my adult life.
I was working on The Master
Puppeteer when I was sent
to the hospital to see
about a suspicious lump
that turned out to be a malignancy.
It was obvious that I--
It is obvious today that I
survived my bout with cancer.
In the year since I have enjoyed
remarkably good health, but in 1974,
I didn't know what
the future would be
or if I had one to look forward to.
Now children are often
afraid of death,
and I certainly was as a child.
But I was 41 years old now
with four young children,
and it was not only
the dread of dying,
but the idea of leaving
my children behind
that I could not bear to imagine.
I knew my lovely husband
would be fine.
There would be women lining up
around the block to snatch him
up the moment I was
out of the picture.
One of them might even turn out
to be a better mother than I was.
But, surely I thought, no one,
however fit to replace me,
could ever love those
children the way I did.
Of course, my death would
not leave my children alone.
They had a loving father and
grandparents and aunts and uncles
and a whole congregation of
people who would care for them.
Lin and John were not
only brother and sister,
but the closest of friends.
Mary had a wonderful teacher with a
daughter just Mary's age who looked
after her while I was in the
hospital and, would, I knew,
continue to care for her.
And David had Lisa.
Lisa had come into our
lives the previous autumn.
The small school that our
children attended was closed
and all the students were moved
to a much larger elementary
school across town.
David, our second grader
was miserable.
In the little school he was both the
class artist and the class clown.
In his new school,
he was simply weird.
Every day he came home and
declared that he was never, ever,
ever going back to that
school and you can't make me.
And I, his mother, who had been
in fifteen different schools
by the time I was 18 and
had been initially despised
at nearly every one,
was over-identifying
with my seven-year-old, probably
exacerbating his misery, but,
nevertheless getting him up every
morning and grimly piercing--
pushing him out the door,
fearing that his unhappiness
would never end.
Then one afternoon, our
bright funny little boy
that I thought was gone forever
came running into the house.
"Me and Lisa Hill are making
a diorama of Little House
in the Big Woods," he
announced cheerily.
I had never heard the name
before, but from then on I was
to hear hardly any other name.
"Now I'd like to promise you girls,"
I say when I'm talking to students,
"that I was thrilled that my
son's best friend was a girl.
But unfortunately,
all I could think was,
they thought he was weird before,
now he's never going to fit in."
But then I met Lisa, and
my worries evaporated.
Anyone would be fortunate to
have her for his best friend.
She was bright, imaginative
and funny.
She laughed at his
jokes and he at hers.
She was the only girl daring enough
to invade the second
grade boys' ball team.
She and David played together after
school in the woods below her house
and talked to each other in
the evenings on the phone.
"It's your girlfriend, David,"
his older brother would say.
But David would take
the phone unperturbed.
Girlfriends are people who
chase you down on the playground
to grab you and kiss you.
Lisa was no more a girlfriend
than Margaret Thatcher
was a Playboy Bunny.
[ Laughter ]
Then on an August morning,
the phone rang.
It was a call from the
Hill's next door neighbor.
"I thought you ought to
know," Mrs. Robinson said,
"hat Lisa was killed this morning."
While the family was on
vacation at Bethany Beach,
on a day when the lifeguards sensed
no danger from thunder far off
in the distance, a joyful
little girl, dancing on a rock
above the beach, was felled by a
bolt of lightning from the sky.
How was I to make sense of
this tragedy for my child?
I couldn't make sense
of it for myself.
So, eventually, I began to
write a story, because I knew
that a story has to make sense.
It has a beginning, a middle and an
end, and when you get to the end,
even if you cannot articulate
intellectually what has happened,
you know emotionally, that you
have come from chaos to order.
In thus spoke Zarathustra,
Nietzche says, "One must have chaos
within to give birth
to a dancing star."
And somehow, as dark as
life itself sometimes seems,
at the end of a well-told story,
the dancing star will
shed light on the chaos.
So, I began to write what I
could not understand or explain,
but when I came to the place in my
story when I knew that if I went
to work the next day I
would write the chapter
in which Leslie Burke would die,
I did the only thing I could do
to keep her alive,
I didn't go to work.
I caught up on my mail.
I rearranged my bookshelves.
I think I was even reduced to
scrubbing the kitchen floor,
anything to keep from
writing the fatal chapter.
It was just then that I
happened to have lunch
with a former Richmond classmate.
"How's your new book coming?"
She asked.
Now, no one, as the
longsuffering members
of my immediate family know all
too well, no one is ever supposed
to ask me how my work is coming, but
Estelle had known me longer than any
of them, and she has no respect.
So I blurted out an answer,
"I'm trying to write a book
about a friendship
between a boy and a girl
in which the girl dies," I said.
"But I can't let her die.
I guess," I added,
thinking I was very wise,
"I guess I can't face going
through Lisa's death again."
Estelle looked me straight
in the eye.
"I don't think it's Lisa's
death you can't face," she said.
"I think it's yours."
I knew she was right.
If it were Lisa's death I
couldn't face, it was one thing,
but if it was my death
I couldn't face,
then I would have to
finish the book.
I went home that afternoon, and
with sweat pouring down my arms,
wrote the chapter and in a
few days finished the draft.
It was the most painful
writing I had ever done,
so painful that I simply could not
stand having it around the house,
so I did what no real writer
would ever do, I mailed the draft
to Virginia Buckley before
the sweat had evaporated.
As soon as I mailed the manuscript,
I knew that I had made
a terrible mistake.
Every day I expected the letter
that would tell me politely,
maybe even a little sorrowfully,
that I had obviously lost whatever
talent I had shown up until then,
that my career as a writer was over.
Instead I got a phone call.
It was Virginia, saying
that she wanted to talk
to me about my new manuscript.
I stopped breathing.
"I laughed through the
first two-thirds," she said,
"and cried through the last."
I began to breath again.
"Now," she continued,
"Let'' turn it into a book."
And then she did what I
believe the great editors do,
she asked me about the question
that would do just that.
"Is this," she asked, "
a story about friendship
or is it a story about death?"
Until that moment, I had thought
I was writing a story about death.
Hadn't it been a year
of death in our lives?
But as soon as she asked the
question, I knew I was wrong.
"Oh," I said, "it's a
story about friendship."
"Then you need to go back
and write it that way."
She went on to remind me that in any
true friendship both friends change
and grow because they
know each other.
"I see how Jesse has changed
because he has known Leslie,
but I don't see how knowing
Jesse has changed Leslie.
How has Jesse made a
difference in her life?"
That was the problem that had to be
solved to turn my pitiful little cry
of anguish into a real story.
And as I pondered it, up from
the dust of the playground
at Calvin H. Wiley School arose
Pansy and her two gigantic cohorts
who had bullied me when
I was a fourth grader.
I meant to leave much more
time for questions and I seemed
to be I don't know who's
flashing things at to me.
I have 10 minutes left,
so let's stop
and at least have a few minutes--
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
The questions are often
the most fun, so.
I just saw in my hotel
room a New Yorker cartoon
in which the writer says,
"That's a very good question.
Would you ask it again tomorrow?"
>> Speaker 4: I have a question--
>> Katherine Paterson:
Is there-- are there--
yeah, somebody is waving back there.
>> Speaker 4: So, I
know you've written--
so you've mentioned how
Bridge to Terabithia came
from your story about your family.
You've also written from your
experiences in China and Japan.
My question is about
Jacob Have I Loved,
which is my personal favorite book.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
So I'm-- yeah.
So I'm just curious where
that story came from and how
that came alive for
you in that process.
>> Katherine Paterson: I have to
tell you I'll be 84 next month
and my hearing-- even with
hearing aids is imperfect,
but I think you're asking
me about Jacob Have I Loved.
>> Speaker 4: Yes.
>> Katherine Paterson: OK.
I wrote the book because
I had lovely adult friends
who would say things to
me like, what do you know,
my mother always loved him best
or if my sister hadn't so and so
when I was seven-years-old, my whole
life would have been different.
And I thought, she's really
strange, these people still hang
up on their childhood jealousies.
And I began to think
about it, I thought,
"This is a universal problem.
We have more trouble with our
siblings than we do with our pairs."
Floyd [assumed spelling]
had it all wrong.
I mean, you go to the Bible,
what's the first murder?
And you'd go through-- and so I
thought, "Hmm, I will write a book
about this universal theme."
And when I sat down to write, I was
so angry, every morning that I sat
down to the typewriter
that I could barely type.
And I thought, "Hmm, maybe it
is not my friend's problem."
But writing a book is a lot
cheaper than psychotherapy.
>> Speaker 4: Thank you.
>> Speaker 5: Hi.
Thank you so much for being here.
I just wanted to-- well, OK, so in
2010, I was about nine-years-old
and I had the privilege to
play Mabel in the Bridge
to Terabithia stage version.
And I always had this
question ever since 2010,
which was why did you
choose to use children
as your protagonists
in many of your books?
>> Katherine Paterson:
Why did I choose--
>> Speaker 5: To use
children as protagonists.
>> Katherine Paterson: Why
do I write about children?
All my books are about children.
You know, if-- it's always
amusing to me when people say,
"When will you get to write a real
book, you know, about adultery
and suburbs or something?"
I truly love writing for children.
I think they are best readers.
I don't-- none of my
friends who write
for adults have readers who've
read their book 17, 20, 30 times.
And I have new generation
of readers coming
up who always want their reading
to be the best book they ever read.
They're reading with
expectation and hope.
And they give you--
they're not cynical.
And there are good readers
and they read in depth.
Whereas adults so afraid
they're not going
to read everything,
they just read too fast.
I do that myself.
So I think I have the
best readers in the world.
I'm not-- after 40 more
years still remain.
Why do I want to write for books
that will be remained in six weeks?
I think-- I have the best
readership and the best position.
And I've been very fortunate through
the years because I've been allowed
to write what I want to write.
I had the same literature [phonetic]
for 40 years, more
than 40 years now.
And I think that's maybe
something of a record.
She's retired now.
And I told her when she
retired, I would, but here I am.
So, it's been wonderful life
for me and I have minutes left.
Well, just go head.
>> Speaker 5: Thank you.
>> Katherine Paterson:
You have a question?
>> Speaker 6: Well, I
like to but a little late.
>> Katherine Paterson: Oh, but
I'm supposed to go back and forth.
>> Speaker 7: As my
kindergarten students would say,
she took my question.
I was just going to open it
up to say what can you say
about Jacob Have I Loved,
that's my absolute favorite book
of yours as well.
I want to change a little bit then
to I'm about to be a mother of two,
I'm an only child, I think identify
with this even as an only child
as the sibling relationship, so
maybe just for the benefit of all.
Any advice on motherhood
of siblings?
>> Katherine Paterson: I think
probably I'm not the person to--
there's a chapter in
this book on motherhood
and then motherhood list than ideal.
And--
>> Speaker 7: Which it always is.
>> Katherine Paterson: And you will
find out what kind of a mother I was
if you read the book and not be too
admiring and not ask me for advice.
I'm just very grateful they all--
four of them have survived me.
And have-- are still nice for me.
Didn't you see that one?
That's way--
>> Speaker 7: You did
something great.
[ Laughter and Applause ]
>> Katherine Paterson: I don't
usually call them sweet, but--
>> Speaker 7: Thank you.
>> Katherine Paterson: --
anyhow, they've been fun
children to live with.
And I guess I was an old mother
and so I was always eager to see
who that would be and how they'd
turn out and never occurred to me
that I ever should tell them
what they should turn out to be.
And they've been-- as my mother just
say, very satisfactory children.
>> Speaker 7: Thanks.
>> Katherine Paterson: So
I've got two minutes left
and I guess we'll take
your question,
I'll try to be a short answer.
>> Speaker 8: OK.
So good afternoon.
My question is more of a general
tactics of how to writing a book.
I've thought about writing
a book, writing something
about my family history back
in China during 1950s and--
from 1950s to 1970s even though
we're just ordinary people,
but I thought about it,
but I ended up giving
up because I think it
will be too detailed,
too much full of the life
routines, things like those.
So, my question is, is there
any method, any kind of magic
to turn all of these and
routine that status quo
of daily life into
real magical book?
>> Katherine Paterson: Any magic?
>> Speaker 8: I can't find a
better term in English, I'm sorry.
>> Katherine Paterson: I
do have a hearing problem.
So what I'm hearing you
saying, you wanted to write
about your family and
your childhood.
And I think frankly,
everybody should do that.
I really do think, just the
process itself is wonderful,
and your children and your
grandchildren will thank you for it.
I-- There's so many things I wish
I had asked my parents [inaudible]
like why in the world
was my mother who grew
up in Georgia really before
people had radios in the house.
Why was she a Brooklyn Dodgers fan?
>> Speaker 8: Right.
Right. Right.
>> Katherine Paterson: So that's
the kind of question you need to ask
and that's the kind of heritage
you need to leave your children.
And I think probably they're going o
be waving those thing and telling me
to shut up, but thank you
so much for being here.
>> Speaker 8: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Speaker 1: This has
been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.